[Musik]
herzlich willkommen alle reden derzeit
über umweltschutz und vivaz klima wir
reden heute über den mann der den
umweltschutz quasi erfunden und als
erster oder im klimawandel gewarnt hat
alexander von humboldt war ein weltweit
gefeierter universalgelehrter und ein
pionier der ökologie vor 250 jahren
wurde er geboren
bereits die halbe welt und hat die natur
ganz neu gedacht kann er uns vielleicht
aber helfen die klimakatastrophe zu
verhindern
darüber rede ich jetzt mit der
historikerin andrea wolf sie ist auf
humboldts spuren durch die welt gereist
und hatte eine vielfach preisgekrönte
biografie über ihn geschrieben herzlich
willkommen
java hat dieser humboldt vor 200 jahren
so etwas wie ein popstar das ist
vielleicht gar keine schlechte
beschreibung humboldt war auf jeden fall
der berühmteste wissenschaftler
seinerzeit der war so berühmt dass wenn
ihn leute besucht haben in paris
wir brauchten seine adresse zum beispiel
nicht die mussten dem kutschfahrer
einfach nur sagen wir möchten gerne zu
alexander von humboldt und dann wusste
jeder wo seine adresse ist wo er wohnte
er war so berühmt dass am
wissenschaftler aus aller welt ihn
besucht haben mit ihm leben wollten
er hat er war so berühmt dass er am ende
seines lebens so viele briefe gekriegt
hat dass er eine eine anzeige in allen
amerikanischen zeitungen geschaltet hat
wohl gesagt hat liebe fans bitte schreib
mir keine briefe mehr ich muss mein
lebenswerk kosmos zu ende schreiben
ich kann eure wenig beantworten und
heute gibt es mehr plätze tiere und
pflanzen die nach humboldt benannt sind
als nach irgendjemand sonst die
humboldtpinguine zum beispiel
humboldtstrom und sie haben dieses
wundervolle buch geschrieben das trägt
den titel alexander von humboldt und die
erfindung der natur hat er die natur
also nicht entdeckt
na ja das ist natürlich so ein bisschen
ein spiel mit worten ich krieg manchmal
leserbriefe die sache herum gold hat
nicht die natur erfunden hätten
natürlich die natur nicht erfunden aber
humboldt hat ein neues konzept der natur
erfunden er hat dass er hat uns ein
konzept der natur gegeben als ein ein
web of life ein netz des lebens oder ein
ökosystem wie wir das heute in den han
lebendiger organismus und sein dieses
konzept der natur hat unsere vorstellung
der natur total revolutioniert war so
etwas wie ein vordenker der
umweltbewegung der ökologie wie ich das
gesagt habe des klimaschutzes vielleicht
sogar also er hat also humboldt war kein
politischer aktivist das muss man glaube
ich an unterscheiden aber humboldt hat
vor den vor dem vom menschen
verursachten klimawandel gewarnt
humboldt hat vor den verheerenden folgen
gewagt die angewandt die angerichtet
worden sind durch rodungen durch
künstliche bewässerung durch monokultur
er wusste nicht den er kannte nicht den
effekt des co2 es auf das klima er
konnte auch nicht an glaube ich wie
zerstörerisch wir werden würden
aber er hat im jahre 1832 zum beispiel
gesagt es gibt drei arten wie der mensch
das klima beeinflussen kann einmal durch
am künstliche bewässerung einmal durch
abholzung und einmal durch die
entwicklung der großen gas und dampf
massen an den industriellen centern also
schon sehr prophetisch würde ich sagen
ein sehr progressiver wenn man jetzt
also einerseits diese naturverständnis
das heute kommt science ist andererseits
auch in politischen fragen als er war
gegen die sklaverei damals vor 200
jahren
er war hat den kolonialismus kritisiert
wie hat er das geschafft seinerzeit so
weit voraus zu sein
ich glaube humboldt war jemand der
dadurch dass er so viel gereist ist also
das war es ja also humboldt ist um die
ganze welt gereist ungefähr humboldt war
fünf jahre in latein
aber er ist auch durch ganz europa
gereist erst durch russland gereist also
humboldt hat ganz viel von der welt
gesehen und war jemand der ganz viel auf
zusammenhänge garten auf globale
zusammenhänge und der zb der erste war
soweit ich weiß der die zusammenhänge
gesehen hat zwischen kolonialismus
sklaverei und umweltzerstörung also er
hat gesehen wie plantagenbesitzer die
umwelt zerstört haben weil sie zum
beispiel zuckerrohr angebaut haben für
den europäischen markt und das
zuckerrohr ist von schlafen angebaut
worden also herr die sind diesen diesen
kreis geschlossen den vorher niemand
geschlossen können sie diese zeit in der
humboldt gelebt hat um 1800 und gedacht
hat ein bisschen grob skizzieren also
was da die politische lage war stand der
wissenschaft und soweit ich glaube das
wichtigste politische ereignis humboldts
leben in der lebens zeitung was war
wahrscheinlich die französische
revolution 1789 ein ereignis das für
humboldt so wichtig war dass er 1790
also ein jahr danach zum einjährigen
jubiläum nach paris gereist ist und auch
immer wieder in seinem leben gesagt hat
in ihm ist der geist der revolution der
1789 jahre evolution also humboldt war
ein liberal denkender mensch der diesen
demokraten demokratischen grundgedanken
der für den der ganz wichtig für ihn war
das ist so das politische glaube ich was
ganz wichtig war und wissenschaftlich
ist es eine zeit wo während des
achtzehnten jahrhunderts zum beispiel
entdeckung wie teleskope mikroskope neue
welten eröffnet haben wo die die natur
durch die mathematik begriffen wurde wo
der menschen mehr und mehr kontrolle
über die natur gewonnen hat also von
blitzableitern bis zu hocken impfungen
dampfmaschinen fruchtwechsel in der
landwirtschaft das große das große
passwort das große motto des das derzeit
war wahrscheinlich fortschritt also jede
generation war neidisch auf die nächste
generation
anders als heute weil man geglaubt hat
die nächste generation lebt in einer
besseren welt weil wir weil die nächste
generation mehr wissen wird über die
welt also die welt hat sich aufgemacht
zu der zeit um holz wissenschaftlich und
politisch nicht unter humboldt hat sich
aufgemacht
er hat nämlich diese diesen traum in die
ferne gehabt dieses fernere die ganze
zeit wurde die ganze welt entdecken und
ist dann 17 99 aufgebrochen nach
südamerika dem heutigen venezuela und
war dann fünf jahre lang da unterwegs
sie musste ich mir das vorstellen damals
irgendwie ohne gps und so ein trip
advisor was es aus noch gibt heute die
war das ist also dann wenn man sich das
anguckt was formal gemacht hat das ist
schon ziemlich crazy also er hat der war
ein sohn einer sehr reichen preußischen
adelsfamilie gibt aber sein doch sehr
privilegiert das leben auf um dann nach
südamerika zu reisen er paddelt auf dem
orinoco lan klettert die alten hosen
runter rutscht seinen körper wirklich
zum absoluten limit am experimentiert
immer wieder mit seinem körper also so
ist ein wissenschaftler der sich selber
in seine wissenschaft mit einbringt sagt
was heißt der experiment also zum
beispiel zum beispiel trinkt er das
tödliche gift das ist das gibt was die
indigenen völker in ihren grußworten
benutzen er experimentiert mit zither
all das sind diese merkwürdigen
eineinhalb meter langen fische die
stromschläge bis zu 600 volt abgeben
können er bleibt sich chemikalien in
seinen in seinen wunden ein also immer
wieder benutzt er seinen körper um die
welt um die welt zu verstehen
und er sagt auch selber ohne experimente
könnte ich gar nicht experimentieren für
diese experimente braucht ihr diese
messgeräte wir haben zwei solche
messgeräte hier diese nicht von humboldt
selbst sondern das hundert jahre später
von einem schweizer arktis forscher auf
nette kerle als mit ihnen durch gründung
gereist
dass sie ist ein so genannter sextant
den brauchte man auf see zur navigation
und das hier ist ein kleiner reise
theodor der zur winkel vermessung das
plateau rund um das tanzen zu messen und
jetzt habe ich in ihrem buch gelesen
dass er über 40 von avaya den schweren
kisten wie wie muss ich mir das
vorstellen teilweise auch noch größere
instrumente er humboldt ist mit 42
wissenschaftlichen instrumenten am durch
lateinamerika gereist er dem die meisten
waren einzeln verpackt in kisten mit
samt ausgeschlagen so dass nichts
passieren konnte die wurden meistens auf
maultiere geladen aber da gab es schon
auch ziemlich prekäre situationen durch
entwendet wenn sie in den anden wo dann
die instrumente so halb über die über
den über den felsklippen rüber hing also
warum wollte auch mal sehr besorgt war
das wichtigste instrument für ihn war
das barometer weil er mit dem barometer
die höhe der berge messe druckmessgerät
genau er hatte einen dienstboten rossi
dessen hauptaufgabe es war das barometer
heil durch ganz lateinamerika zu
und ich habe gelesen dass erst das erste
was er gemacht hat als er am strand zu
jeder angekommen ist er hat thermometer
genommen und in st
also hat wirklich alles vermessen und
die seiten gesammelt jähriges muss genau
wir haben die karten angereist ist über
teneriffa daneben nach neu granada hieß
das damals noch und dann vielleicht
können sie kurz sagen was so die route
dann ist sozusagen von commander ist er
dann durch den nach caracas und dann
durch den llanos was sind die steppen
venezuela zum orinoco und den
nebenflüssen dort dann ging es hoch
nördlich nach kuba dann wieder nach
südamerika dach katharina bogotá quito
bis nach lima am von von bogotá bis nach
lima 2009 4000 kilometer durch die anden
wo er wirklich also jeden erreichbaren
vulkan geklettert
der insel irgendwie über diesen weg
haben sie ja noch gehör ist für das buch
und auch noch für eine
fernsehdokumentation für terra x1 zdf
was hat diese reise dienenden gemacht
also und wie hat die ihren krieg wenn
also erst mal ich leider bin ich kein
reicher am adels sohn einer preußischen
familie deshalb konnte ich nicht fünf
jahre durch die gegend reisen aber was
ich versucht habe sind so die
wichtigsten punkte am zu bereisen
für mich war das ganz wichtig diese
landschaften auch zu spüren ich weiß
nicht wie das andere schriftsteller
machen ich kann keine landschaften
beschreiben die ich selber nicht gesehen
habe was mir aber auch ganz wichtig war
es humboldt hat zwar auf der einen seite
seine 42 instrumente durch die gegend
geschleppt aber immer wieder hatte
gesagt es sind nicht nur empirische
daten sondern wir müssen auch die natur
fühlen
und genau das war für mich auch teil der
recherche nicht nur in den archiven zu
sitzen was ich auch viele jahre getan
habe sondern diese landschaften die so
wichtig für hummeln waren die auch
teilweise sind große schlüssel
erlebnisse fina waren selber zu erleben
also ob das auf dem logo war oder zum
beispiel zum tempora zu auf den anti
sana das waren alles momente wo ich dann
zum beispiel auf den chimborazo habe ich
die tagebucheintragungen die humboldt
mitgenommen hat mitgenommen und dann da
oben gelesen und irgendwie ihm auch
irgendwo emotional näher zu kommen also
das war mir auch ganz ganz wichtig dass
das nicht nur intellektuell war sondern
auch emotional weil das für humor selbst
auch wichtig dieses dieses wachstum war
humboldt ist jemand und das vergessen
wir immer ganz gerne
der wird gerne dargestellt also der der
verrückte mit seinen instrumenten aber
humboldt hat immer wieder gesagt wir
müssen die natur fühlen
wir müssen diener wir müssen die
fantasie benutzen wir müssen unsere
vorstellungskraft benutzen wir müssen
unsere sinne benutzen wenn wir die natur
verstehen wollen und das ist etwas was
mir ganz wichtig in beiden haben war
dass das durchkommt das humboldt eben
weil ich glaube weil das etwas was heute
total fehlt indes
schafft kein wissenschaftler in
zumindest in diesen ganzen peer reviewed
artikels erlaubt sich die gefühle mit
einzubringen aber ich glaube dass heute
in unserer diskussion mit dem
klimawandel dass das etwas ist was ganz
ganz wichtig ist wo wir ganz viel von
humboldt lernen kinder weil gefühle
vielleicht nicht objektive sind deswegen
gehören sie finden nicht in die
wissenschaft aber fürs handeln sind sie
hat ganz relevant jetzt in sachen
klimawandel dass wir die natur nicht nur
irgendwie in zahlen vermissen sondern
genau auf den zauber oder so genau also
diese event wer also ich glaube zum
beispiel ist der der das wunder der
natur das war etwas was humboldt
angetrieben hat auf diesen reisen und
ich glaube das ist etwas wenn ich heute
über die verhandlungen im klimawandel
nachdenken zumindest in einem
politischen in der politischen arena
vermisse ich dass keiner sich so richtig
traut über den zauber der natur zu reden
darüber dass wir wir werden nur das
beschützen was wir lieben glaube ich
dass wir sind keine statistiken sondern
das ist so wenn wir wenn wir zum
beispiel immer nur über den ansteigenden
säuregehalt des meeres reden aber nicht
darüber reden was für ein genuss wir
haben wenn wir im wind am strand stehen
und diese wählen um uns herum spüren
dann fehlt uns was glaube ich und ich
glaube dass humboldt 100 hat immer von
der von der von der kommunikation der
natur mit unseren inneren gefühlen geht
und ich glaube das ist etwas was heute
fehlt und warum zb des freitags
verschärfen und glaube ich ganz ganz
wichtig ist weil die kinder und teenager
sich trauen über ihre gefühle zu gehen
und sagen wir wollen dass er in panik
wir wollen dass ihr genau die gleiche
angst spürt die wir jeden tag spüren und
die haben eine emotionale dimension zu
dieser debatte gebracht die bis dahin
gefehlt geführt sagt geführt genau wie
haben sie eben kurz gesehen vor dem
tempel wo diesem
größten berg in ecuador der den 108
bestiegen hat damals dachte er sei der
höchste berg der welt sie selbst sind ja
viel rumgereist nicht nur mit dem buch
sind sie jetzt in der ganzen welt
unterwegs seit zwei jahren sondern sind
in indien geboren sind dann nach
deutschland gegangen leben jetzt in
london in england sind sie selbst eine
kosmopolitin vielleicht wie um und
rastlos wie humboldt vielleicht auch ja
also ich habe meine meinung mit indien
das habe ich ja nicht selber entschieden
dass meine eltern entschieden aber ich
bin dann bin dann nach der schule haben
nach england noch gezogen und bin werd
dann irgendwann werde ich immer unruhig
war nicht zu lange an einem ort bin ich
glaub ich glaube ich also ich sag mal so
ich fühle mich sehr ich fühle mich wie
humboldt auch als weltbürger ich fühle
mich nicht als als er als deutsche oder
auch nicht als britin sondern ich fühle
mich als weltbürger und ich habe oft ich
treffe menschen überall in der welt die
mir näher sind als vielleicht mein
nachbar zu hause
also ich glaube schon dass wir in dieser
globalisierten welt leben und das reisen
war für mich immer ganz wichtig um diese
welt auch zu verstehen
vor kurzem wurde in eine große ehre
zuteil sie haben nämlich solche medaille
gekriegt hier im explora das klappt und
vielleicht erzählen sie mal kurz was das
ihnen bedeutet und wie wichtig ist also
der explorers klappt ist ein klub in ein
ganz exklusiver club in amerika gibt
seit 1904 und das man eigentlich ein
explorer sein um da mit diesem sektor
oder beigetragen haben zur forschung
nahm die haben ganz viele also ist eine
große ehre wirklich weil die eine die
haben ganz viele fans fast gehabt also
die mitglieder die zuerst auf dem mond
zuerst auf dem nil armstrong war
mitglied dort zuerst am südpol armen
hillary auf dem auf dem brett sagt
piccard der tiefste mehr also das ist
das ist schon fast das ist schon fast
eine zu große ehre damit lädt zu sein
und das ist eine dass man kriegt wenn
man mitglied jetzt kriegt man diese
medaille die habe ich immer in meinem
portemonnaie und die reist immer mit mir
mit als glücksbringer
sie haben vor diesem buch oder vor der
beschäftigung und umbau der bücher
geschrieben über den garten der garten
das ist ja die gezähmte natur etwas
einfach gesagt vielleicht sie haben
bücher geschrieben das heißt das sound
im garten muss über die gründerväter der
usa und ihre gärten und ihnen die
fernsicht ihre politik vorstellung in
den gärten spiegelt was fasziniert sie
dann persönlich mehr so nicht zu der
gezählt die geordnete garten oder die
wilde natur ist im tun ich würde das ja
ich würde das gar nicht zu unterscheiden
und ich würde auch sagen dass die dass
die bücher für mich sind das alles
bücher über das verhältnis zwischen
mensch und natur und wie wir die natur
verstehen und wie wir die natur
behandeln und für mich zum beispiel das
buch über die die die gründungsväter in
amerika das war sehr da habe ich den
garten sozusagen benutzt als ein fenster
in die polin das politische aber ich
glaube dass wir das alles nicht
voneinander getrennt haben erhalten
können also genauso wie wie humboldt die
natur als ein reich der freiheit sieht
das als inspirationen sie zum beispiel
dass wir keine sklaverei haben sollten
genauso kann ich sehen wie die
gründungsväter in amerika ihre gärten
benutzt haben um politische statements
zu machen als zum beispiel george
washington hat am tage am abend vor dem
vor dem von der schlacht von new york
1776 hat er seinem seinem estate manager
von mount vernon gesagt er soll den
ganzen garten rausreißen alle englischen
bäume ausreißen
für mich ist das so eine gärtnerische
declaration of independence
also und anja hat wollte nur
nordamerikanische bäume und sträucher in
seinem garten haben also ist ein ganz
starkes politisches statement über den
zusammenhang von kultur und politik bei
humboldt werden wir gleich noch
reduzieren ich habe noch die figur oder
den menschen gesagt rastlos wie ist er
denn aufgewachsen war seine kinder
alexander von humboldt hat selber von
sich behauptet dass er eine sehr
unglückliche kindheit hatte sein bruder
wilhelm hat das auch gesagt beide söhne
wilhelm war zwei jahre älter beide söhne
haben sich sozusagen nicht geliebt
gefühlt von ihrer mutter die mutter war
relativ emotional kalt der vater starb
sehr sehr jungen und die die die jungs
sind also in tegel bei berlin
aufgewachsen wilhelm hat sich in seine
bücher geflüchtet und alexander hat sich
in die in die natur geflüchtet war ja
der große bildungsforscher
sprachforscher dem ja gesagt der
geisteswissenschaft genau der
sprachphilosoph sozusagen der der
bildungsminister von von preußen der die
universität von berlin auch gegründet
hat und alexander ist also schon als
kleiner junge durch den wald hat sich
die tassen taschen vollgestopft mit
insekten mit pflanzen wurde von seiner
familie als der kleine apotheker
bezeichnet und hat schon als kleiner
junge von der großen weiten welt
getroffen aber er fühlte sich immer
einsam fühlte sich einsam fühlte sich
unverstanden war kränklich was man sich
heute gar nicht vorstellen kann weil er
diese unglaubliche reise überstanden hat
und dann fast 90 jahre alt wurde
aber ich glaube eher humboldt hat sich
ganz stark von der preußischen
gesellschaft eingeschränkt gefühlt
damit kam dazu dass er gerne die
wissenschaften studieren wollte und
seine mutter hatte aber andere karriere
vorstellen wollte dass die beiden söhne
im preußischen staatsdienst anfangen zu
arbeiten
der kompromiss war dann besser zu werden
weil das der einzige beruf im
preußischen staatsdienst war wo man
wissenschaftlich arbeiten musste weil
man die neuesten wissenschaftlichen
kenntnisse
in der geologie muss und dann starb die
mutter 1796 humboldt mitte zwanzig
begeistert im grunde genommen also beide
söhne sind nicht zur beerdigung gegangen
innerhalb von vier wochen hat seinen job
gekündigt und fing an seine große reise
vorzubereiten also das war wie so eine
erleichterung löste und das große
vermögen hatte er so dass er sich diese
leiten diese reise auch leisten und weil
humboldt anders als andere
entdeckungsreise ist humboldt privat als
privatmann gereist also nicht im auftrag
einer regierung oder eines königs
sondern hat selber entschieden so zu
sagen aber er musste die erlaubnis haben
von diesen kolonialmächten und sport ja
auch nach indien nach dem himalaya hat
er habe nicht geschafft haben wir hinten
gelegen haben die drehten haben sich das
angeguckt wie humboldt die spanier
kritisiert hat in südamerika
kolonialisten genau und hat daran haben
dann gesagt warum sollen wir diesen
diesen querulanten diesen preußischen
querulanten nach indien lassen damit er
dann über ihn über die britische
kolonialmacht eher schlecht schreiben
das hat er nie geschafft hatte auch bis
zum ende seines lebens wirklich bereut
hat der beziehung lebensbeziehungen also
homburg hat nie geheiratet
humboldt war der berühmteste
wissenschaftler seiner zeit und es hat
niemals eine frau gegeben die gesagt hat
sie hatte eine affäre mit ihm also die
meisten historiker ich ziemlich da auch
dazu gehen heute davon aus dass humboldt
homosexuell war inwieweit er das
körperlich ausgelebt hat wissen wir
nicht
er hatte sehr intensive freundschaften
mit jungen männlichen wissenschaftlern
aber wie weit er das wirklich körperlich
ausgelebt hat werden wir erst wissen
wenn wir irgendwann brief finden wo er
das beschreibt es gibt diese eine
interessante stelle die sie auch in
ihrem buch haben beschreibt diese
körperlichen strapazen sie haben gesagt
der hat den eigenen körper als
instrument benutzt und diese berge
bestiegen und so die helfen auch dabei
von einem bestimmten trieb sondern
wissen abzulenken oder den zügen zu mir
ja so also er beschreibt das dass er das
so zu sagen diese körperliche
anstrengung die leidenschaft unterdrückt
und
es gibt dann das argument dass es seien
und dass er vielleicht ließ seine
sexualität nicht ausgelebt hat und dass
er deshalb diese unglaublichen
körperlichen strapazen auf sich genommen
hat weil das ist wirklich also was
humboldt gemacht hat zum beispiel in den
anden
das ist das ist schon unfassbar also wie
er da also wie sie über diese ahnten
hoch und runter also mit schlimmsten
schuhwerk immer wieder sind ihnen die so
in der schule zum beispiel zerrissen in
eisiger kälte in tropischer hitze und er
hat das alles immer weiter sich immer
weiter hoch betrieben weiterhin ist
einerseits so was wie ein stein aber
andere sagt so was wie einen reinhold
messner irgendwie in einer person
das ist unsere aufgabe aber ein
unglaublich ja das ist rum um bolt ist
wirklich ein mann der gegensätze so muss
man ihn auch wirklich verstehen also auf
der einen seite ist ja jemand der der
erfahrene bergsteiger seinerzeit ist auf
der anderen seite ist jemand der
wirklich die größten erkenntnisse hat
auf der einen seite ist ja jemand der
den ruf hatte ziemlich zynisch zu sein
und auch mal ablästern kommt oder leute
nach der anderen seite hat er immer
künstlern und wissenschaftlern in not
geholfen also es gibt diese beiden sein
was sind glaube ich auch interessante
persönlichkeit also man darf ihn auch
nicht auf so ein podest drauf setzen und
sagen der große held humboldt lassen sie
uns jetzt ein bisschen über die
erkenntnisse reden sie haben das schon
angesprochen diese erfindung der natur
bestand darin die natur nicht aus
maschine zu sehen sondern aus netz aus
organismus aus lebewesen vielleicht
sogar und das ganze kommt in einen in
einer grafik zum ausdruck die heißt
natur gemälde das hat er gemacht und
zwar sieht man auf diesem bild den jim
brass zu diesem werk und ganz viele
linien woher diese klima und
vegetationszonen die er entdeckt hatte
sogleich über den ganzen globus hinweg
war diese globale perspektive war dass
das revolutionär humboldt ist der gibt
viele sachen die revolutionäre sind aber
eine sache ist also er sieht die er
sieht die die erde als einen lebendigen
organismus
er spricht von globalen vegetations und
klimazonen also er sieht er sieht
verbindung über die ganze welt also
man muss sich vorstellen andere
wissenschaftler haben sich die welt
angeguckt in im system der
klassifikation also die haben sozusagen
die natur eingepfercht in dieses korsett
der klassifikation immer kleiner werden
und humboldt hat genau das gegenteil
gemacht hat alles miteinander verbunden
hat alles global gesehen hat alles immer
miteinander verglichen
also nicht unterteilt sondern verbunden
das ist glaube ich so dass wichtige und
das sieht man im natur gemälde auch weil
er dort die pflanzen eingezeichnet hat
auf dem auf dem champ orad zu lassen die
kleinen schwarzen striche lösen jetzt
eingetragen auf der höhe war sie
gefunden hat links und rechts haben wir
20 spalten wo er alle möglichen
wissenschaftlichen daten gibt alles
sachen die er errechnet hat gemessen hat
schwerkraft die chemischen
zusammensetzung der der atmosphäre man
kann man eine linie ziehen und dann
kriegt man alle informationen über 5000
meter ist ja ein kunststück der
wissenschaftsvermittlung bildgebendes
verfahren sind ja so ähnlich ist ja also
ich würde um wollt also ich bezeichne
ihn auch eigentlich so als vater der das
was wir heute infografik nennen also
humboldt hat immer wieder daran geglaubt
dass die wissenschaften dem
demokratisiert werden müssen also er hat
geglaubt dass wissen macht ist er hat
seine bücher geschrieben fürs oder viele
von den büchern hat er geschrieben für
das allgemeine publikum
er hat seine wissenschaftlichen daten
die so eng ausgedruckt also er hat aus
brüllt er hat immer wieder versucht die
kunst und die wissenschaft miteinander
zu verbinden oder sagen wir mal so er
hat sie nie getrennt
das ist ja eine relativ neue entwicklung
für humboldt hat das eine was mit dem
anderen zu tun
sie haben gesagt die natur aus lebewesen
aus organismus denken wo alles
miteinander zusammenhängt hat die natur
dann auch ein ziel ein zweck für hamburg
strebt irgendwohin nach mehr komplexität
ich weiß es nicht ich glaube so sieht er
das gar nicht ich glaube er sieht das
mehr als das ist die ganze welt die also
er hat jetzt nicht diesen
evolutionsbedingt wie charles darwin am
sondern
also er spricht zwar auch von der von
der von den veränderten arten aber
humboldt entwickelt wie ich glaube es
ist ganz wichtig humboldt entwickelt nie
ein ganzes system humboldt ist so
rastlos und neugierig der geht in eine
richtung der gegen die andere richtung
aber dieses dieses natur als organismus
das ist für ihn mehr ein
wie gesagt das ist dass das ist ein
system in dem alle jedes jeder
organismus einem einen platz hat er
spricht davon dass ein leben ist
ausgegossen über steine insekten
menschen pflanzen
wir sind alle teil dieses netzes das ist
ich glaube er sieht das meer wie sowie
ein netz nicht unbedingt mit einem ziel
ich möchte mit ihnen noch über diesen
wichtigen aspekt sprechen den sie schon
erwähnt haben nämlich dass die natur
nicht nur vermessen wird sondern auch
erfahren wir erlebt jetzt also natur aus
erfahrung
und sie haben schon gesagt glaube ich an
goethe hat er geschrieben die natur muss
geführt werden erstand er in kontakt mit
mit goethe goethe hat ihn besucht
ich weiß es nicht mehr genau er hat auch
schüler in jener besucht damals vor der
reise noch er hat auch immanuel kant
gelesen
das heißt er hat sehr viel austausch
gehabt mit dichtern und philosophen
wir haben die denn sein denken oder sei
naturverständnis geprägt da kommt also
humboldt hat sehr viel zeit in jena
verbracht also teilweise monatelang sein
bruder wilhelm lebte in jena haben in
jena hat er dann goethe und schiller
getroffen und das war eine ganz ganz
wichtige zeit für rowohlt und zwar haben
sich humboldt und die humboldt und
goethe gegenseitig ganz stark
beeinflusst goethe damals natürlich der
berühmteste dichter am seinerzeit war
mitte 40 und war mitte 20 und goethe war
nicht nur dichter sondern hat sich auch
ganz stark für die wissenschaftler
interessiert und was ihm aber fehlte
waren wissenschaftlicher sparringpartner
und dann tauchte dieser
das sind heute hier die neugierige junge
humboldt auf und die beiden haben also
zusammen experimentiert die haben beim
gleichen seziert und frösche und mäuse
die haben vorlesungen besucht die haben
sie unterhalten ist nach spazieren
gegangen
die haben gegenseitig ihre schriften
sich vorgelesen und haben also ganz
staat sich ausgetauscht so dass goethe
gesagt hat meine natur historischen
arbeiten sind aus dem winterschlaf
geweckt worden warum alexander von
humboldt und humboldt hat gesagt dass
goethe ihn mit neuen organen
ausgestattet hat und zwar waren dass
diese organe die welt anders zu sehen
also er kam in jena an
als empirica als wissenschaftler der
aufklärung sozusagen und es war goethe
der immer wieder sozusagen gezeigt hat
dass auch unsere sinne wichtig sind um
diese welt zu verstehen da war dann auch
immanuel kant ganz wichtig also kannte
hatte gesagt der oder diese diskussion
zwischen dem dualismus zwischen der
innen und der außenwelt was kant gesagt
hat ist dass der mensch sozusagen bürger
zweier welten ist am die außenwelt hat
das ding an sich werden wir niemals
richtig erkennen können
die innenwelt unsere welt der
wahrnehmung ist immer subjektiv die
kategorien und unserem verstand von raum
und zeit entscheiden wie wir diese welt
sehen also das leben hat die welt wie
sie von uns erfahrungen aber munter
unseres dahinter ist unsere sinne sind
sozusagen wie eine getönte brille durch
die wir die welt sehen und damit wurde
die subjektivität wichtiger und das war
ganz ganz wichtig für humboldt also der
sozusagen von seiner empirischen
forschung von seiner
wissenschaftliche messungen hat das hat
er dann verbunden mit den emotionalen
reaktionen zur natur genau wir sehen
hier im bild noch beide gebrüder
humboldt mit schiller und goethe
da in jener und was jetzt schluss gesagt
haben also diese für diese subjektive
element dass das ins spiel kommt das
wird auch unseren heutigen debatten ums
kleber und um die natur
sagen sie uns sie haben nach dieses
wundervolle kunstvolle buch
herausgegeben zusammen mit willi an
märchen vielleicht können sie dazu kurz
was sagen dass da die idee jetzt da die
idee war dass man das also was mir ganz
wichtig war weil diese auch die
künstlerische seite von humboldt zu
zeigen und md der ausschlaggebende grund
war die die legendären humboldt
tagebücher aus lateinamerika waren im
privatbesitz bis ende 2013 sollen dann
wurden die gekauft und waren auf einmal
der öffentlichkeit zugänglich und als
ich diese tausenden von seiten gesehen
habe mit humboldts gibson und dann war
mir irgendwie klar ich wollte ein buch
machen was auch diese seite zeigen ich
wollte diese manuskripte auch zeigen
dass kann man in einer traditionellen
biografie natürlich nicht weil das
hauptsächlich auf wörtern und nicht
aufzeichnung bucht aber hier haben wir
halt ein buch gemacht wo wir ganz viel
rum bolz eigene eigenen manuskripte
benutzt haben also er schwimmt durch
seine angel ist natürlich gerade keine
seite er schwimmt durch jetzt zum
beispiel eine seite wo er das zelt
aufzeichnet wo sie übernachtet haben in
den anden was was ich wollte was sind
eure genau zu erfüllen sein
mit illustrationen was ich wollte wollte
sind ist es so ich wollte ein buch
machen
das zeigt dass ein wissenschaftler das
emotionale das künstliche künstlerische
haben kann aber trotzdem ganz präzise
messung macht und gedanken hat und
wissenschaftlich arbeitet
neben diesen künstlerischen moment
gesagt dass politische bei humpeln
darüber möchte ich jetzt mit ihnen noch
wissen reden
die natur habt ihr gesehen als reich der
freiheit das haben sie schon mal gesagt
und hat sein politisches ideal irgendwie
auch aus diesem natur ideal abgeleitet
also der hohe wert der freiheit hatte
den letztlich aus der natur genommen und
ist irgendwie natur für die narren
vorbild für politik ist ich glaube ja so
humboldt hat die natur oft also die das
reich der freiheit genannt die republik
der freiheit und hat gesagt genauso wie
in der nati es in der natur keine
überlegenen unterliegenden organismen
wesen pflanzen gibt sondern alles hat
seine daseinsberechtigung genau so ist
das mit den mit den menschen es gibt
keine unterlegenen oder überlegenen
menschen also die die
deshalb kann es keine sklaverei geben
also der anlass in sachen die haustüren
das ist ungemein hat sagt das ist
lawaree ist unnatürlich und das größte
übel der menschheit hat immer sein
ganzes leben lang das kritisiert aber
ist die natur nicht auch ein kampf was
uns dann natürlich darwin und chor
gelehrt haben das kampf ums überleben
ist ein kampf ums überleben aber das
kann aber es ist trotzdem ein dass es
das ist nicht dass die das eine dass
eine menschenmasse sozusagen der anderen
überlegen ist also das ist das eine hat
nichts mit dem anderen zu tun für ihn
sondern dass es in der natur ring
regiert die natur sozusagen oder die
lebenskraft aber nicht der mensch der
mensch ist nicht die ich glaube das ist
das wichtig der mensch ist nicht die
krönung der schöpfung und kann das aber
auch nicht die natur zerstören
und da ist ja dadurch diese länder
bereisen hat er unterschiedliche
indigene kulturen kennengelernt hat das
fand ich ganz interessant nicht auf die
rumpel geblickt wie viele damals sondern
mit ungeheurer wertschätzung entwickelt
diese kultur ja also erholt hat
ist durch südamerika gereist durch
lateinamerika gereist und hat immer
wieder anders als andere europäer die
die indigenen völker als barbaren
gesehen hat er hat immer wieder gesagt
das sind die besten
beobachternatur das sind die besten
geografen die ich getroffen habe hat
ihre sprachen gesammelt hat am war
fasziniert von ihrer art die natur am 2
also dass die die das religiöse der
religiöse aspekt der natur bewunderung
der insel den verdacht dass also immer
wieder in seinem in seinem tagebuch
notiert war also sehr offen und man darf
natürlich nicht vergessen die indigenen
völker haben ihn durch den urwald
geführt also er hat auch gesehen was sie
wussten was sie konnten hat später zum
beispiel auch geschrieben dass die
sprachen das ist kein abstraktes
europäisches philosophisches konzept
gibt was nicht in einer sprache der
indigenen völker ausgedrückt werden kann
also ganz ganz anders als das was die
anderen europäer zu der zeit gesagt
dieser humboldt man kann ja nicht nur
gut finden gibt es auch schattenseiten
ihrer vorzeige figur
man muss dazu die schotten sein also es
also humboldt darf man nicht auf dem
podest setzen humboldt war jemand der
hat den ruf dass er schwer ablästern
konnte ich glaube humboldt hatte nicht
besonders viel geduld für dumme menschen
humboldt konnte ohne punkt und komma
reden also das haben wir wirklich so wir
haben ganz viele zeitzeugen berichten
die gesagt haben also wenn humboldt
innenraum kommt kriegt man kein einziges
wort reinsch als damen hat das auch
gemerkt als er um bald das erste mal
kennengelernt hat humboldt ist jemand
der zwar verstanden hat wie der mensch
die natur zerstören kann
aber er hat das nicht in politischen
aktivismus umgewandelt also das hat er
dann sozusagen der nächsten generation
überlassen humboldt hat war so rastlos
so neugierig dass er nie irgendetwas
wirklich zu ende gedacht hat sondern
dann wieder irgendwie abgelenkt worden
ist
anderem und etwas anders gemacht hat
also es gibt schon einige sachen und hat
er nicht auch ein ambivalentes
verhältnis zu diesem kolonialismus weil
er ist ja irgendwie hat diesen
kolonialmächten auch informationen
beschafft also einerseits sind in
spanien über diese gebiete und später
ist er dann nach russland gereist
auftrag des zaren und hat dem
irgendwelche informationen gegeben über
über gold verfolgung ist also in
russland die russlandreise am 1829 die
hat humboldt gemacht weil er nicht nach
indien gekommen ist und russland war zu
sagen sozusagen soweit nach asien wieder
kommen konnte
die wurde bezahlt also vom russischen
zar er musste ein vertrag unterschreiben
dass er nicht über die zustände der
bevölkerung schreiben darf also der der
der russische zar wusste ganz genau dass
das sonst passiert aber was humboldt
gemacht hat ist dass er trotzdem noch
einen riesengroßen umweg von mehreren
tausend kilometern
doch zum altar gewebe zu kommen aber das
stimmt schon also er ist er hat zum
beispiel der glaube der russischen
zahlen versprochen dass er ihr diamanten
findet weil er gesagt hat dass
uralgebirge ist genauso wie die gebirge
in brasilien wo es diamanten gibt also
hat das vorher gesehen und da kann dann
sozusagen sein wettbewerbsgedanke durch
und er hat dann auch prompt die ersten
diamanten in russland gefunden
noch mal zurück in die usa oder nach
amerika der thomas jefferson hat ihnen
ja auch eingeladen nach nach washington
hat mich total überrascht
also der dritte präsident der usa und
und verfasser der
unabhängigkeitserklärung was wollte der
chef von humboldt also humboldt war ein
jahr in mexiko und hat dort auch viel
zeit in den archiven verbracht und viele
daten gesammelt über bevölkerung über
landwirtschaft über handel
beim militär und thomas jefferson hat
1803 das lousiana territory gekauft für
die usa damit die größe der usa
verdoppelt und mexiko war der neue
nachbar der usa humboldt kam also aus
mexiko nach norden nach nordamerika und
jefferson hat humboldt bombardiert mit
fragen über mexiko und humboldt der an
diese an die republik der gelehrten
geglaubt hat hat also freudig seine
seine notizen auf gemacht seine karten
dem den den amerikaner gegeben zum
kopieren also das ist so alles dinge
alles daten die eigentlich den spanien
gehört hat er sozusagen das einleben und
jefferson also das war genau das was ja
was natürlich wollte und erfassen war
dann total begeistert von humboldt aber
dazu muss man auch sagen dass sowohl
jefferson als auch unbedingt humboldt
sind diese universalgelehrten also
jefferson oder auch ganz fasziniert von
der wissenschaften zum beispiel und die
haben sich also auch wissenschaftlich
sehr stark aus betrachtet nicht nur
politisch aber es gab zum beispiel auch
diese freundschaft zwischen humboldt und
simon bolivar den lateinamerikanischen
unabhängigkeitskämpfer der ja dann
irgendwie diese nation von den kunden ja
auch mächten befreit hat war der
humboldt er eine inspiration für so
figuren wie bolivar hier also humboldt
hat humor bolivar haben sich
kennengelernt am 1804 in paris da war
bolivar noch ein junger wilder party
feira sozusagen
und als er dann zurück kehrte nach
lateinamerika und dann dort die am
kolonien befreite hat bolivar humboldts
bücher benutzt einmal um informationen
über latein amerika zu gehen weil bulli
war kam aus venezuela aber humboldt war
überall gewesen also humboldt hatte ganz
viele informationen die boulevard nicht
hatte aber was glaube ich noch viel
wichtiger ist dass bolivar später gesagt
humboldt hat hat südamerika mit seiner
feder aufgelegt also die beschreibung
humboldts von lateinamerika als dieses
dieser meist dieses majestät dieser
majestätische kontinent mit diesen
unglaublichen bergen und flüssen hat
bolivar gesagt hat sozusagen die die
südamerikaner aufgeweckt und stolz
gemacht auf ihren auf ihrem kontinent
und er hat auch immer wieder bulli wart
immer wieder die metaphern aus den aus
der natur benutzt um seine revolution zu
erklären ganz stark angelehnt an
humboldt hat immer wieder davon
gesprochen wir stehen auf einem vulkan
der kurse vom explodieren ist oder hat
gesagt die freiheit ist eine kostbare
pflanze also hat die beiden haben auch
weiterhin korrespondiert dann
miteinander also natur immer als
metapher für politik für politische
ideale und so weiter und auch für die
die stärke die städte südamerikas wurde
ausgedrückt durch zum beispiel die an
diesem ästhetischen großen berge bekam
wurden ein symbol für dieses für diese
jungen nationen die sozusagen die die
tyrannei der spanier abwerfen wollte wie
ist das mit so großen vorzeige figuren
wie gut sie haben gesagt er hat die
schattenseiten aber die werden ja auch
von der geschichte immer
instrumentalisiert oder das geschieht
auf war das bei humboldt auch so ich
würde schlechten zeit ja also humboldt
ist in verschiedenen zeiten
verschiedenen benutzt worden
ich glaube aber das passiert sowieso
immer also jeder historiker wenn
irgendeine historiker behauptet sie sind
total objektiv das kann man gar nicht
sein natürlich sieht man diese
historischen figuren durch durch die
linse sozusagen durch die durch die
durch das die scheibe unserer heutigen
zeit nicht die scheibe des
einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts ich
glaube aber humboldt ist eine ehrlich
gesagt einer der wenigen die man relativ
gut hinstellen kann heute als gute
europäer also der hat relativ wenig
daneben gehauen in seinem leben so also
er ist er sie irgendwann ist ihm
vorgehalten worden dass er also
wieso imperial ist durch südamerika
gereist ist dass es wirklich nicht der
fall es gibt eine einzige einen einzigen
moment wo er wirklich daneben haut das
ist also ein grab plündert am weil er
die skelette haben will
für die wissenschaft das ist aber
wirklich also in den im ganzen tagebuch
sagen diese ganzen 4000 seiten ist das
einzige mal dass mir eine also sondern
eine begebenheit beschrieben worden ist
wo ich das okay da da ist er wirklich so
der klassische entdecker aus dem 18 19
jahrhundert leer neugier mit ja und er
auch herunter guckt und der sagt also
eure grabstätten sind nicht so wichtig
wie meine wissenschafters das war am
orinoko es gibt ja auch die debatte
darüber über diese kolonialisten
raubkunst und so weiter jetzt vor allem
in berlin die debatte um das
humboldt-forum also ausstellungen über
außereuropäische kulturen sind da sind
all diese gegenstände die solche leute
wie umbauten mit nach europa gebracht
haben würden sie ihm da etwas vorwerfen
also ich finde das ist ein ganz ganz
wichtige debatte ist und ich finde das
muss intensiv diskutiert worden ich
glaube nicht dass man alle museen auf
einen schlag leer räumen muss humboldt
hatte interessanterweise relativ wenig
mitgebracht einfach weil er nicht so
viel transportieren konnte das was er
hauptsächlich mit gebracht hat waren
aufzeichnungen und waren pflanzenproben
also 60.000 getrocknete pflanzen hat
mitgemacht nicht so nicht so viele nicht
so viele kulturgegenstände wie man denkt
als er zum beispiel ein paar jahren
liefen mitgebracht aber das meiste hat
er kopiert in dem
in den archiven dann spricht auch wieder
diese wertschätzung einfach die er hatte
für diese kulturen und für diese
menschen jetzt aus heutiger sicht
was können wir von humboldt mitnehmen
was ist ein beitrag sie haben schon ein
bisschen so angetönt in sachen in dem
gegenwärtig laufenden debatten um
klimawandel aber auch um migration
vielleicht was würden sie sagen müssten
wir von oder können die von humboldt
mitnehmen in unserer zeit für mich ist
glaube ich das wichtigste das humboldt
die die wissenschaft und die kunst
zusammen bringt also dass rational und
das emotionale was ich einmal ganz
wichtig in der debatte des klimawandels
finde da habe ich ja vorhin schon drüber
geht aber ich glaube auch dass man das
noch größer sehen können wenn wir werden
ja heute schon also kinder im alter von
sechs jahren werden der im grunde
genommen in der schule schon in diese
schublade geschoben
logisch wissenschaftlich mathematisch
oder kreativ künstlerischen das sind
glaube ich ganz das ein ganz großes
problem in unserer gesellschaft dass wir
das schon so viel machen das ist eine
sache glaube ich wo wir in der
inspiration von ihm annehmen kann und
auch dass er was gehört das konkreter
ist ich glaube dass man zum beispiel
nicht mehr nur mathematik getrennt von
der kunst und der wissenschaft
unterrichtet sondern dass man die jetzt
so ganz spontan ich sag mal wenn wenn
man wenn es wenn man über astronomie
redet dann kann man über am kometen
sprechen dann gibt es mehr oper über
kometen dann gibt es die zeichnung die
gemacht worden sind dann gibt es die
mathematik dahinter dann gibt es die
physik des universums dahinter also dann
gibt es die gedichte die über kometen
geschrieben worden sind dann hat dann
kann man darüber sprechen was das in der
religion bedeutet hat ich glaube dass
man diese verbindung vielmehr schaffen
muss und was hilft das was das hielt ich
glaube dass wir dadurch viel am
gesamtheitliche menschen werden kann und
nicht nur ich glauben wir können in der
person humboldt haben wir diese ganzen
sachen zusammen er konnte diese
verbindungen sehen das schafft heute ein
mensch gar nicht mehr alleine weil das
wissen wie zu groß ist das heißt wir
müssen miteinander zusammenarbeiten
wissenschaftler mit künstlern
ein beispiel ist zb es gibt ein künstler
einen fotografen kam robin preis der hat
durch experimentelle fotografie kann der
die feinstaubpartikel in der
luftverschmutzung fotografieren sie
sehen aus wie so kleine lichter die
blinken und anstatt zu hören 30
milligramm pro kubikmeter zeigt er ein
foto mit ich sage von der küste wales wo
so ein paar lichter drin bringen oder
von neu delhi wo es voll geknallt ist
und für mich sagt dass manchmal mehr als
zahlen und ich glaube dass künstler mit
wissenschaftlern zusammenarbeiten können
um zum um zum beispiel unser wissen über
den klimawandel klarer zu machen
deutlicher zu machen und ich glaube dass
das deshalb wichtig ist dass wir schon
in der schule anfangen das nicht so zu
trennen
sie haben einmal ein gespräch gesagt die
natur ist für sie auch ein wunder
worin besteht dieses wunder genannt dass
das ist ja genau das was man nicht
erklären
das geheimnis das ist dass ich glaube
das ist etwas das hört sich jetzt ganz
fürchterlich esoterischen aber ich
glaube dass es was was passiert mit
meinem herzen und meiner seele wenn ich
in der natur bin und ich meine damit
nicht nur wenn ich oben auch mit tempora
zu stehen sondern das kann auch sein
wenn ich in meinem schlafzimmer in
central london liege und den den morgen
chor der vögel höhere und und mich freue
oder wenn ich mich freue auf einmal in
einem busch ganz viele bienen zu sehen
und denken sie okay es gibt noch welche
da das ist ein wunder dass spricht
irgendwie zu mir nicht auf einer
rationalen intellektuellen ebene sondern
das geht mir direkt in die seele oder
ins herz und ich glaube dass wir alle
dieses gefühl haben müssen immer wieder
das glück das ist und dass es wie ein
menschenrecht das gehört zu uns dazu
weil wir aus der natur kommen weil
unsere fantasie sich in der natur
gebildet hat vor zehntausenden von
generation schafft das kunst bei ihnen
auch diese erlebnisse zu wecken
manchmal ja musik gerüche aber natur
weil ein natur ist es am einfachsten
das können auch geräusche der natur
seien es sehr interessant bei immanuel
kant gibt es eine stelle beschreibt
natur ist dann schön wenn sie wie kunst
aussieht und kunst dann wenn sie wie
natur
dann können diese beiden zum schluss
letzte frage angenommen sie könnten
humboldt irgendwann mal im himmel
treffen
was würden sie ihn fragen was wollen sie
unbedingt von ihm wissen ich glaube ich
würde ihnen gerne fragen ob er
irgendwelche großartigen ideen hatte zum
klimawandel heute weil er das nie zu
ende durchgedacht hat und weil ich
glaube dass wir jemanden dass wir
menschen die so über die außerhalb ihrer
disziplin disziplin denken können wie
humboldt solche menschen brauchen ich
glaube das würde ich ihn fragen aber
auch vor allen dingen weil ich das immer
gefragt werde was würde humboldt denken
wenn er das heute sehen würde weiß ich
nicht würde ich ihn gerne fragen was wir
da sagen also ihrer sicht ich weiß ich
weiß dass ich etwas einzige was ich dazu
sagen kann ist immer dass ich aber eine
tagebucheintragungen gefunden wo er
schon im jahre 1801 eine sehr düstere
zukunft voraus sieht wo er sagt es
könnte sein dass die menschen irgendwann
zu fernen planeten reisen und wenn das
passiert nehmen sie ihre tödliche
mischung aus arroganz und ignoranz mit
sich und werden diese fernen planeten
genauso veröden lassen wir unsere echt
jetzt 1801 ja ferne planeten ausreichen
denn die werde nicht mehr beliebter ist
ich meine dass wir jetzt arbeiten wir
daran die heutigen entdecker gehen ja
nicht mehr nach südamerika sondern auf
den mars sind da die neuen humboldts zu
finden ich weiß es nicht ich glaube ich
glaube warum bald bei humboldt ich das
geht
das ist das ist so eine eine lust
gewesen weg zu gehen auch an ich weiß
nicht wie sehr das ob das das gleiche
gefühl ist wenn man auf einem mars
fliegen würde weil es so weit weg ist
dann aber vielleicht machen die anderen
damals genauso weit wie der mars heute
unglaubliches risiko auch damals man
muss ja fast
ja verruf vielen herzlichen dank für
dieses gespräch
ich denke ja nächste woche spricht mein
kollege wolfram eilenberger mit der
preisgekrönten us amerikanischen
historikerin the poor über die
geschichte der usa von der gründungsidee
bis zur gegenwart und jetzt gleich
erfahren sie welche aktuellen schweizer
kino fehlt mir etwas taugen und welche
nicht der film talk in der sternstunde
kunst und zum schluss noch eine
anmerkung in eigener sache ich werde sie
und ziemlich erst im februar wieder
sehen in der zwischenzeit gehe ich
meinen pflichten als zweifache papa nach
kommen sie also gut durch den winter und
einen schönen sonntag
[Musik]